all the heavy elements that we find on
earth
were originally synthesized that's made
inside stars
astronomers are now studying the
mechanism in which these elements are
formed inside the stars now they know
that somewhere in the universe there
will be every element at least the ones
that are not radioactive inside
different stars but the problem is to
detect a particular element in a star
and some elements like the element
solarium had not been discovered in
stars before now just to remind you I
need to put a glove on here here is the
sample of tellurium in fact there are
two samples there's one here inside this
block and there's a rather nice
bell-shaped piece and you can see that
tellurium when you look at it on earth a
large lump looks rather like a silvery
metal it's not a metal its so-called
semi conductor but it shines rather like
a metal the reason why I'm using a glove
is because if you absorb till urine in
your body it gives you terrible smells
coming out of your body
which I don't want and you probably
don't either I can pick up a lamp like
this and I in principle I can do
analysis and show it's to Liam Brady
found a recent press release here from
MIT Massachusetts Institute of
Technology announcing that some of their
astronomers had discovered evidence for
the existence of tellurium in the star
now the press release was clearly not
written by a chemist because it begins
rare earth element found in far far away
and tellurium is not a rare earth but we
can forgive them that and there's a
paper which talks about did detection of
the second our process R stands for
rapid ich element tellurium in metal
pool stars this is a physics journal so
I don't know the me
all those things but the actual
experiment they did is quite easy to
understand now as you can guess the only
thing that you can measure easily from
the star is the light that is coming
from it you can't travel there with your
test tubes what the basis for this
experiment is is that every element will
have a characteristic fingerprint of the
wavelengths of light that it can absorb
so you can look at a little peak of
absorption and say that's two Lehrer
more that's chromium or that's iron now
unfortunately for this particular
experiment the region in which tillering
absorbs is very short wavelength
ultraviolet light round about 230
nanometers or 2300 angstrom units this
is a region where the Earth's atmosphere
absorbs so the crucial light that you
need to detect early room is absorbed in
the atmosphere so if you point your
telescope from the ground at the star
you just can't see anything you can't
tell whether there's tellurium there or
not so what they did was to use the
Hubble telescope which is out in space
so there's no air in the way and so they
can look at the stars without worrying
about the absorption here is their
spectra from three different stars and
this is the wavelength around about 2385
angstrom units so you can see there's a
really tiny tiny piece of the spectrum
here and these Peaks here show where
light is being absorbed and you can see
there are a lot of them it's like
looking for a tree in the forest and
there are three of these because they're
from three different stars which have
these rather and romantic names of HD
and then a lot of numbers the important
peak is here you can see it's not very
big
but that peak there convinces the
scientists that they have found
tellurium in the stars now from the
point of view of chemistry this is not
terribly important chemists are only
interested in lumps of tellurium and
using it to make chemicals so the fact
that it is in stars that are so far away
that nobody could possibly ever travel
there is an interesting fact for the
coffee-room but it's not something that
is going to lead to a whole new area of
chemical production on the other hand
the more we can understand about how our
universe originated and how the elements
originated is valuable it's a very good
test of the theories of how elements are
formed and so on and the aim of science
is to try and improve the picture of the
world or the universe we live in and
it's never finished because once we have
got the broad outline they're always
details to be filled in and sometimes
those details will show that theories
are wrong a lot of scientists even if
they're not astronomers are fascinated
by astronomy I'm quite interested by it
but I feel so sick and get such big
headaches when I look through a
telescope that I've met all filled
glasses that I've never really done much
astronomy but it is a very sobering
thought to realize that there are these
enormous ly complicated processes that
have occurred millions of light years
away
billions of years ago that have created
the chemicals that we're using today and
if you want to find out more you can go
to Brady's new channel called deep sky
videos all about what happens in the
depths of space and there is the website
written right there so go and have a
look at it or you can keep watching
periodic videos but also as a special
treat for this
we're going to be using that the Isaac
Newton telescope to take an image of it
these are nice to see probably better
image with something like a DSLR camera
because you can capture the star colors
fairly quickly and highlight before they
start doing some real work so let's head
down